mercury is a fascinating material even I
enjoy playing with it but like most
heavy metals it is poisonous is quite
surprising to people if you have this
liquid running around in the dish or
something how can it possibly poison you
if you're not touching it the answer is
that there is vapor of mercury coming
off which you can breathe and remarkably
it's quite easy to show you how this
vapor comes off before we show you the
experiment I have to explain a little
bit about mercury lamps UV light can be
generated by filling a tube with a small
amount of mercury and then passing
through an electric current the electric
current heats the mercury to very high
temperature and the mercury atoms give
out ultraviolet light this is like you
can't see and the ultraviolet light is
at a very precise wavelength around 254
nanometers so now neil has one of these
lamps quite an old one but it still
works and let's see what happens when he
shines it across the surface of a dish
of mercury to make the effect a bit
easier to film he's warmed the mercury a
bit but it's not very warm probably less
than a hundred degrees centigrade like a
cup of tea or something like that we as
humans cannot see UV light our eyes
don't detect it in order to see the
output of the lamp you have to shine it
on the sheet of paper which contains a
dye to make it look white you know paper
is usually a bit Brown and that dye
absorbs the UV light and gives out a
sort of purplish color of light so
that's why the piece of paper that Neal
is holding is glowing purple in between
the lamp and the paper there is vapour
coming off the mercury not very much but
the mercury atoms in the vapor
can absorb precisely the same wavelength
of light as the lamp is giving out so it
acts as a very precise and powerful
filter for the light so the paper
doesn't glow as brightly and you can see
these clouds of swirling vapor and those
clouds of the mercury vapor which if you
had your nose
close to it you would be breathing in
and that's why liquid mercury is
dangerous because all the time
vapor is coming off and mercury is one
of the elements which can accumulate in
biological systems like your body so
even if the mercury is coming off slowly
if you're exposed to a long time you can
absorb quite a lot and there's stories
of old lab buildings where they used to
use mercury where when they're doing a
refurbishment they lift the floorboards
and underneath there pulls the mercury
which have fallen through when people
have spilt it over the years in some of
these places there is quite a high level
of mercury vapor that is coming up
through the floor though usually it's so
dirty under the floor that there's a
layer of dust which prevents most of it
coming off but the take-home message
with this is that if you're using
mercury and there are all sorts of
experiments where it's useful to use
mercury you must use it in a fume hood
that's well-ventilated so you don't
prove the vapor from the vapor pressure
in the air and he dropped in the mercury
what's interesting is that as it goes
into the liquid nitrogen the nitrogen
boils and so the mote crew Falls almost
encased in the sort of bubble of
nitrogen gas